we've already made great progress on
this ian we um since 2015 we've achieved
45 reduction in our carbon emissions per
order um but we've got to collaborate
more we're looking for different
technologies different ways of moving
products and actually increasing the um
the number of last mile deliveries that
are done by electric bands so those are
some of the areas that we are um we are
seeing as obstacles but actually in it's
time to do things differently it's time
to be bold these are ambitious goals
because we think it's important we know
our customers want us to do it our
research shows a little over 25 of our
customers in the gen z category
particularly are looking for brands to
make these changes do you worry then
that uh were you not making these
changes they they might take their
business elsewhere is that an imperative
so we think it's an imperative let's
let's um refer to it as future proving
our future demand we believe customers
will increasingly choose brands that
share their values share their ethics
and values and ethics are important for
them
now you also want all of your own brand
materials and packaging to be 100 made
of recycled material by 2030 are you
going to have to compromise on quality
or cost in order to do that
well i'm also happy to say we've made
we're making great progress on this too
so 85
of um asos design which we verified
pre-pandemic is already made from
sustainable cotton one of the things we
want to improve and is in our goals this
morning is increasing the use of
sustainable and recycled fibres
within packaging uh we're around 90 of
our plastic outer bags already recycled
material and 100 recyclable and of
course all our cardboard is um recycled
and recyclable but we're looking at
making even further steps forward to
actually improve the uh and reduce the
plastic waste
but will customers have to pay a little
more for some of these developments
so there'll be some marginal cost
increases over over the next nine years
of our goals but actually we um with
collaboration and new technologies we
think we'll offset those but also we're
expecting greater demand for our
existing customers and new customers too
now you're not only targeting changes on
the environmental front today you're
also uh promising to make 50 of the
management teams senior management teams
female and 15
ethnic minority representation by 2023
have you got people in the business to
do that are you going to have to go
outside to do that
so excellent we're lucky asos one
because we already have a diverse
working environment and
and at the moment we have around 42 of
our leadership positions are female
around 19 from ethnic minority our job
here is to actually make sure that that
talent can flow through to the very top
of the organization we know
representation is really important to
our customers and we know it's really
important to our people so we're
committed to make that change and we
need to do more here the why behind that
ian is we get better products better
solutions better experiences for our
customers and will management bonuses be
contingent on hitting these targets
so my bonus and incentive package has
already had an element of what we call
fashion with integrity within it and
over the coming weeks we'll as we set up
our new targets will ensure that all
management have an element of fashion
with integrity goals within their
incentive packages and who will be
auditing that i mean you're not going to
be marking your own homework presumably
so one of our goals is on transparency
and transparency is we we would like to
see that as radical transparency the
radical transparency means commentators
customers at people can actually hold us
to account and all those findings will
be audited by the board and our external
authors as well
and sorry i should also mention we work
with these goals in with some critical
friends so such as
anti-slavery international the carbon
trust so we've got a lot of critical
friends making sure we're standing
behind our commitments is all this an
acknowledgement that fast fashion might
not have been as ethical in the past as
it could have been
well we think it's time to make boulder
changing so the way things were
were produced in the past is not good
enough and we're committed to making
better change we need to work across
industry we need to work with our
partners our suppliers to make these
changes that actually the the
organization wants us to do our
shareholders want us to do and our
customers as i said earlier also want us
to do as you say you've got critical
friends who are advising you uh on on
this
are you benchmarking yourself at the
same time against any of your
competitors
i don't see this as a competitive um set
actually in i actually welcome the fact
that more and more people are
aware of their impact on the planet and
actually are working together and more
working together to actually drive the
changes that all of us need to happen
and then while we've got you i know
there's a lot of talk at the moment
about supply chain bottlenecks how are
you trading your way through that
situation have you had any major
setbacks
so we i highlighted this um several
months ago um and we're pleased to
have a great warehouses around the world
that are seen as employers of choice
we're working very hard to ensure that
we get the right people to deliver the
right product for our customers at the
moment that they need them so it's
definitely an issue in but we're working
hard on it agile model and the fact that
we have around 85 000 different products
also means we have plenty of options for
customers